طبعا قصه الكلاب الضاله في الاردن اخذت
عنوانا عريضا خاصه بعد تكرار بعض الهجمات
يعني كان اخرها مقتل طفل ولكن
الحكومه الاردنيه محافظ الزرقاء ممثل
بمحافظه الزرقاء وصلوا الى حل وهو ايواء
الكلاب هذه على يعني تفريغ مساحه معينه
قطعه ارض لاواء الكلاب الضاله
وتعقيمها وتلقيحها واطعامها لتخفيف يعني
ازمه هذه الكلاب خاصه وانها تحتاج فعليا
لمن يرعاها هي كائنات حيه هي ارواح تحتاج
لهذا الشيء ولكن هذه التجربه وهي يعني
ايواء هذه الكلاب في قطعه ارض مخصصه مع
جمعيات الرفق بالحيوان ستخضع لتجربه لمده
90 يوما خاصه وان هذه الكلاب ايضا تتعرض
لبعض العنف من البشر من الخوف وهي بالتالي
تقوم بايذاء البشر وانا الان موجوده مع
بعض الكلاب التي كانت توصف ولكن مع
تدريبها وايواءها استطاعت هذه الكلاب ان
تكون اقرب الى البشر ان تخفف من يعني
مشكله اعتداء الكلاب الضاله في الشوارع
نحن في الاردن يعني الكلاب والقطط ايضا
الضاله والمتشرده تعم الشوارع في المناطق
السكنيه لذلك الحكومه الاردنيه وصلت الى
حل وهو عدم قتل الكلاب او تسميمها كما حدث
في الفترات الاخيره ولكن عمليا تبحث عن
حلول انسانيه لواء هذه الكلاب كما ترى في
الصوره هذه الكلاب كانت يعني في الشوارع
وتم ايواءها والان تعاد الى اماكنها
الطبيعيه او يتم تبنيها من بعض الراغبين
بتبني الكلاب وهذه يعني الحلول الانسانيه
نحن دائما نبحث عنها لان الرحمون يرحمهم
الله وبالتالي نحن ايضا نقدر حياه الانسان
ويعني الجميع يخشى على اطفاله في ساعات
الليله المتاخره او صباحا ان يعني مجموعه
من الكلاب الضاله تقوم بالتعدي على هذا
الطفل وخاصه ان هناك طفل فقد حياته اثر
تعدي كلب ضال عليه ولكن الحكومه بدات تبحث
بحلول بعيده عن القتل بعيده عن تصميم
الكلاب بعيده عن اطلاق النار عليها وهي
ايواءها في اماكن مخصصه واطعامها وتلقيحها
وتعقيمها وبالتالي هذه الحلول الانسانيه
التي تبحث عليها يعني الحكومه الاردنيه من
جديد القطط
انا امتلك نعم انا اوي كلبين كلب كنعاني
وكلب صغير وعندي ما يعني ما يبلغ 40 50
قطه ولكن قطتي من الحالات الخاصه يعني قطط
فقدت اعيون البيت قصدت اقدامها قطت تعرضت
للضم من بعض يعني
في البيت عندي الله يجازيك خيرا ان شاء
الله سها جميل شكرا جزيلا لك